and we're back so when did the
interesting questions start oh right now
actually this is but this one's a little
bit leading and this one is why are so
many screenwriters opposed to structure
I I didn't know they were my experience
is my experience is that there are there
are two groups of screenwriters now it
used to be I mean you probably remember
in the 90s and the early 2000s there was
the Chris Vogler book which is pretty
good actually
and then the true B book and who's the
guy that charges almost as much as the S
seminars I'm not gonna mention this name
there used to be like this is how you
write a screenplay and I think that
particularly in TV screen plays and
teleplays that's that's changing I would
like it again to me structure will
automatically is the easiest thing to
learn that's that's the craft of that's
not even to me the craft of it I could
basically teach anybody how to structure
a screenplay and I'm not and I'm lucky
to have Peter cuz he's really I'm not
joking around now he's really good at
structure but I believe structure comes
out of character in conflict so I have
not run up against a lot of writers who
are opposed to that I just think a lot
what some teachers do is they teach
structure Oh before they'll teach
character or conflict which is a big
mistake
because it'll be an I've read things
that are beautifully structured and
empty their software now you can get to
structure your screenplay
Mariners makes a whole bunch of software
programs that's easy I could teach you
that in formatting and structuring in a
week but I hadn't heard what you what
you're hearing are you hearing that a
lot of people are opposed to structure
it was a question Oh see what your
answer was I hear the opposite I hear
people fall back on structure they're
not so much in TV I guess
a bunch of really funny videos on
YouTube of fake pitches have you seen
those no and brilliant they're
hysterical there's a wonderful one on
there pitching Citizen Kane it isn't
caracal and with the wind but there's
I'm trying to think of the one that I
really love because we're talking about
structure here pulp fiction
oh and explaining you know these these
pages are all out of order don't worry
we made the story flow in a logical
sequence now and so I mean I think again
like many other areas that the concept
of structure is evolving also and but
that started a long time ago that price
started in the 60s with the new French
novel and stuff where all of a sudden
you don't know if you're seeing a
sequence or are you seeing a composite
or if you're how which part is fantasy
in somebody's head and which part is
real and so the whole notion of
structure has been evolving a lot so
things aren't necessarily as linear as
they were people are taking a lot bigger
liberties that way which is a good thing
I think you have to write the way that
no I'm not talking about being in a room
then you've got to observe the rules
that the showrunner lays out but if
you're writing something of your own and
if for example I always tell students
and I tell myself that if you are
awakened at 3 o'clock in the morning and
a scene comes to you get up and write it
down
and don't worry about where it goes in
the structure because if you wait you
might still be able to write the scene
but it won't have the power and the
passion you felt woke you up for a
reason and a lot of writers particularly
students are afraid to do that because
they've had pounded into their head that
you must write everything in order and
that's the mark that makes me crazy the
writing things in order how can you know
there's a famous quote how could I
forget who said it I'm blanking on
everything today but I do know franchise
now I'm not gonna forget that that how
do I know what I think till I see what I
say Oh
that powerful is this what Adam has got
above his desk yeah is that good so you
got a new quality for him I mean I think
that a lot of people are afraid to just
dive into that I am it's hard to just
dive into that darkness and then let it
be bad and find the structure but make
sure that you find it from the
characters because otherwise it'll be
empty do you find certain students or
people that you've worked with are okay
going to those places and others are
really whether it's their upbringing are
fair-skinned nobody's okay with knowing
so to get them to be okay with it and
what I did in my teaching I created I
co-created a course a couple of years
ago a remade course for freshmen and it
was the first day of class a week it'll
be a week tomorrow and I said to
everybody in the room get ready to
embrace oh-ho are you gonna have to
erase that No okay so it's the am LeMat
dictum from bird by birth you have an
obligation to be shitty oh you know
which um you should you can almost see
the the weight come off their show at
the most is the closest I feel of being
like a therapist since I'm releasing
them from the need to be good and they
can write because then I say that
because you're going to be anyway you're
18 years old how good are you going to
be and I don't give you a good grade for
being good and then they go wait a
minute if we try to be good you're not
gonna grade us better than people who
try to be bad exactly because I don't
care I'm interested in the process not
the product you're a teen doesn't matter
how good it is it's still gonna suck you
know that word we can't use I'm sorry
I'm sorry
eighteen yes no I mean this is a very
big thing with me this this need people
have and I think it's because I am and
I'll always be a recovering
perfectionist that that is another thing
the partnership has given me because he
forces me to put it down and you know if
I if I if I had my druthers
not so much anymore but I used to be
that we just take forever because I
didn't want to be bad yeah the P word is
a synonym for scared yeah exactly
oh I see right right uh-huh I'm afraid
it'll suck and if you tell students at
the beginning it's okay to suck it's
okay to be bad you it's like Peter said
earlier then you have something that's
on paper you can play with it forever
but if you don't put it down you got
nothing you were talking this morning
about a guy who's been working for five
years in the screenplay
five ten ten five I could except you
know it's not like he's writing the
Great American Novel he's writing a
screenplay come on really well unless
he's so lost in the process because they
should be writing three screenplays not
one double-spaced 12 pages a year now
put the man oh no I I think I think that
it is just fear you know and older
people can have fear too sure because
then yeah I think it's it's okay to be
young and to fail and make mistakes but
older people we have two worst days of
my life for the days that I finish a
play or I finish something and I my
first reader is always my wife because
she's an actress and she'll say nice
things and then she'll say so basically
what you're asking me to do is put
marbles in my mouth to say these lines
you know and it's and after I get over
being hurt and thinking about divorce
court and all of those things I you know
she's right again we're writing for
actors we're not writing
yes producers have to read it executives
have to read it but you're gonna be
replaced really fast if you can't write
dialogue
you